i get up super early uh generally i have  this thing where i like beating the sun  up not just in terms of before the sun  comes up i have to get up um  and uh how do i do it it's just  important to find balance and i try and  do things really that i really enjoy  doing and a lot of times you know it's  like in life right life brings like  drama and you got to deal with this  person and [ __ ] your relationship here  and all these things you try and just  kind of balance them out as best i can i  got a great team around me by the way  who really really helps me well and  helps me allows for me to come in and  work 12 hours a day 14 hours a day get  up at 3 o'clock in the morning  uh send out an instagram video where i'm  talking to my cardio machine like a  crazy maniac  so yeah it requires a lot of people  around